der russische Präsident Vladimir Putin
hat heute eine Teilmobilmachung von ca
300.000 Soldaten der Russischen
Föderation angekündigt um seinen
Kriegszielen in der Ukraine noch mal
Nachdruck zu verleihen wir schauen uns
heute kurz an was das bedeutet und wie
das militärische umsetzbar ist und
Berthold
300.000 Soldaten aufzubringen ist
natürlich eine Herausforderung und da
gibt es zwei Aspekte den personellen und
natürlich den logistischen Aspekt das
personeller Hinsicht muss man sagen wo
sind die Leute woher kommen die Leute
welche Leute sind das überhaupt und das
logistischen
Hintergrund oder was man logistischen
Aspekt muss man sagen diese Leute müssen
ja nicht nur aufgebracht werden das
Personal aufgebracht werden die müssen
auch ausgerüstet werden das heißt man
muss sehr viel Gerätschaft Panzer
Artillerie aus der langzeitkonservierung
holen braucht der entsprechendes
Personal dazu um das herauszuholen und
das kampftauglich zu machen genauso wie
man auch Personal braucht Berufs Militär
Personal dass er jetzt zu großen Teil
sich im Krieg befindet dass man mal
eigentlich dazu bräuchte um diese mobil
zu machenden Kräfte zu formieren und
auszubilden und das ist sicher einer der
Punkte und warum so eine mobil machen
insbesondere in dieser Dimension wo man
sich vorstellen 300.000 ist doppelt so
viel wie das was in der Ukraine im
Einsatz ist 150.000 dass das schon
Monate dauern kann um solche Massen an
Leuten aufzubieten auszurüsten und
feldverwendungsfähig zu machen ich
glaube was man sicher erkennen kann ist
dass der russische Präsident selbst
bemerkt hat dass es der Krieg wir jetzt
geführt wurde mit der Kampfstärke wir
geführt wurde so nicht weitergeführt
werden kann ohne dass er Probleme
bekommt seine Kriegsziele zu erreichen
daher war diese Maßnahme offensichtlich
notwendig sie verlängert natürlich damit
auch den Krieg also eine frühzeitige
Beendigung dieses Krieges wie es viele
hoffen ist also damit sicher
auszuschließen noch dazu weil ja wie
Berthold gerade gesagt hat diese
Mobilmachung relativ lange dauern wird
und die Soldaten hier nicht sofort
wirksam werden können was ist der Zweck
was können die machen was können sie
erreichen diese Soldaten naja es gibt
drei Möglichkeiten im großen Pflanzen
die man da machen kann einerseits kann
man mal die Fehlstellen und das ist eine
relativ sage mal das ist die schnellste
Möglichkeit diese mobil zu machen
Soldaten einsetzen wir wissen es gibt
sehr viele gefallene verwundete aber
auch geflüchtete russische Soldaten das
heißt man könnte sehr rasch diese
Fehlstellen ersetzen eine zweite
Möglichkeit wäre es die bereits sieben
Monate im Einsatz befindlichen
russischen Soldaten einmal auszutauschen
hier eine Rotation durchzuführen das
heißt Soldaten die seit sieben Monaten
im Krieg im Kampf stehen einmal nach
Hause zu holen und auszutauschen und
eine dritte Möglichkeit wäre natürlich
auch dass man sagt man nimmt schon
formierte Einheiten die jetzt nicht in
der Ukraine im Einsatz sind sondern die
noch an der Grenze zu NATO-Staaten
stehen an der Grenze zu China Stehen
bringt die in den Einsatz und nimmt
diese neuen teilmobil gemachten Kräfte
um in diesen
in der Intention deutlich geringere
gefährdeten Gebieten diese teilmobil
gemachten Einheiten einzusetzen
sozusagen ein Austausch von stehenden
formierten hätten gegen diese teilmobil
gemacht Einheiten an der Grenze zu China
oder dann Grenze zu Polen oder im
Praktikum das wäre natürlich
Möglichkeiten und du sprichst es ja an
also wir haben hier eine Frontlinie in
der Ukraine von ca 1200 Kilometern die
rechte so im Endeffekt vom Südwesten aus
dem AOK kiff wo derzeit ukrainische
Angriffe laufen über mariopol die Stadt
dieser lange sehr heißen kämpft war bis
hinauf bis hinunter eigentlich in den
Raum Herren wo ebenfalls noch die
russischen Soldaten derzeit in die
Defensive gedrängt wurden von
ukrainischen Kräften welche Optionen sie
ist dafür diese 300.000
ja
ganz am Anfang muss man glaube ich
einmal feststellen es wird heute nichts
passieren und es wird morgen nichts
passieren also ganz klar ist es dass es
Zeit dauert und je nachdem wie die
eingesetzt werden sehr schnell sehe ich
die Option dass man dort wo die auch
Einheiten sehr stark ausgedünnt sind
oder sehr große Verluste hatte Soldaten
hinbringt und das wird genau an dem von
Dir angesprochenen
schwergewichtsbereichen sein im Norden
wo man jetzt entlang des oskill-flusses
versucht eine Verteidigungslinie zu
halten aber auch im Süden wo man unter
Druck ist nicht nur ein care sondern
auch auch dazwischen wo sich er
möglicherweise eine dritte ukrainische
Offensive
ankündigt aber generell glaube ich dass
es ganz klar der Hintergrund ist dass
man Einheiten vermiert Einheiten
aufbringt um genau das zu machen was
Wladimir Putin ja im Frühjahr dieses
Jahres angekündigt hat wie man von der
sozusagen gesamtumfassung reine
abgegangen ist und als neues
strategisches Ziel militärstrategisches
Ziel die Befreiung des dompass
ausgegeben hat als ich denke dass man
ganz klar bei diesem Schwergewicht
bleiben
will und diese Kräfte dort zum Einsatz
bringen will um dort eine Entscheidung
herbeizuführen und nicht nur die ganzen
Bereich noch Hans den man ja mehr oder
weniger zu gäns in der Hand hat sondern
auch ganz Oblast den ganzen Bezirk Don
jetztk zu erobern mit diesen grifften
das wird wahrscheinlich der erste
Schritt sein und der Krieg wird dann
noch weitergeführt werden wir gehen
davon aus dass die strategischen Ziele
nämlich vor allem die Ukraine zu einem
Staat zu machen der sich nicht im Westen
nicht der NATO nicht der EU annähert
sondern Russland freundlich sein wird
dass dieses Ziel unverändert bleibt und
ich glaube wir beide sind da einer
Meinung daher wird dieser Weg auch noch
viel länger dauern ganz genau